you
you're watching age 2 3 3 30. those
glasses on
just last minute can you pop up you want
to pop up the
dark part are you like oh they come
right off oh my god you don't care about
those at all
impressive welcome back ela
ela kleiner's rejoice
shredders say hi to everyone
shredder has this tenant whenever anyone
collapsed he just barked yeah
i think he just wants to participate
maybe that's his version of clapping
yeah
right you want to test it round of
[Laughter]
applause
oh today's episode's sponsored by
hellofresh and upstart
how are you today how are you good
i'm so happy to be back in
the best country in the world with the
planet
hell yeah brother usa
usa no i'm not i'm not trying to this
israel but you know yeah look israel's a
tougher place nicer here
israel's a tough place it's a little bit
nicer
so i'm happy to be back and i missed
everyone
you did yeah
deeply everybody missed you i brought
some
uh israeli gifts for the crew oh
this one is like a traditional black
coffee
oh yeah all right you just drank that
with um hot water
can we brew some and do a taste test can
we get
olivia is it whole beans yeah you don't
need to do anything you just need hot
water
oh this is what they call turkish coffee
yeah where the the grounds
oh yeah yeah i've had turkish coffee
gotta let it sit at the bottom you don't
want to mix everything they call it mud
in israel yeah it's good
yeah my grandma used to predict the
future with that people
yeah any accurate predictions oh yeah
people do that they're all like very
generic
right yeah i think she ripped off a lot
of people to be honest she's like i
predict that
tomorrow will the sun will
come up pretty much
and then your uncle will die something
like uncle will die
what the hell it's a little more
dramatic very specific
though oh my god it's white clock game
everybody
and that's right it's friday
it's friday baby [ __ ] yeah baby [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] baby yeah i'm i'm in
front of starbucks
i hate it i hate it whoa wait you hate
something what's wrong with starbucks
it's howard he's a chose
um i hate that guy wait which guy what
happened
our trolls oh yeah oh
he sold the beloved super sonic to um
play bennett
and then move that team to oklahoma city
that's how the thunder
started
most hated guy it's sports stuff yeah
yeah so we're just saying we're just
giving a shout out to [ __ ] starbucks
right now today
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] [ __ ] day [ __ ] yeah cool
anything else going on gabe how you been
we haven't talked to you in a couple
weeks
well we've been busy and stuff
we're working on this merch right here
let me see let me
get a good look at that wait
is that fried chicken fried chicken
wednesday fried chicken you deserve
fried chicken baby [ __ ] oh
oh yeah whoo it's gonna send us some
gabe is right you're sending us some
he's sending us some merch nice
get them soon before it's all gone oh
yeah
yeah absolutely it's so nice to hear
from you
you know after two weeks did you miss us
oh yeah i
i miss you guys yeah i miss you too by
the way
all right man well have a great friday
it's friday baby drinks kick down some
white clothes for me okay
oh sure definitely it's the weekend baby
it is the weekend isn't it
all right take care baby [ __ ] yeah maybe
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] baby
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] baby white claws
[ __ ] baby all right take care buddy
we'll see you soon okay all right all
right appreciate you
that is white claw gabe with a
[ __ ] starbucks on this beautiful friday
afternoon
so oh boy check check out oh the
market's closed but i was gonna say
check their stock right now
it's gotta be tanking yeah it's got the
tank wondering if it's tanking right now
um back to where i was
uh white clock gabe on cameo everybody
if you want a personalized uh
shout out from him please go ahead i
also brought harvard
i don't know if you guys had it it's um
it's like a snack
but it's healthy oh that is not healthy
well
kind of no it's made of sesame it's made
of sesame
fat and sugar it's like healthy fat
keto baby moms will tell you that it's
healthy this ain't healthy
i'm surprised it's just a block of fat
and sugar
i don't know about that it's a it's a
dessert
well it's a dessert
this is actually my dad's favorite snack
there you go the parents
love it yeah well they're fooling
themselves it ain't hunting
and then i brought little magnets
that have the they have hebrew slang
words on them
is that real it also says in english and
in arabic how to say it
oh wow okay so yeah
that is as if yani yeah
oh that's german i'm a [ __ ] such a
weirdo
okay um
bottom line the topless is
i don't know
the end of the way baby there's nothing
better the best
yeah sofa there all the way
yep hamsa i know what and that's also
what you call the evil hand right
right it's a hamsa the good luck
that's not really slang is it did that
yeah
one by one yeah para also means cow
but you can say by cow you can say
and yes means
or yes yeah and then uh yeah
that's it everybody gets a magnet you
get a magnet and you get american
well ela i don't know i know you've been
busy and you weren't able to really keep
up with everything we've been up to
since
we've been gone so we made a little
compilation for you
to catch up on what we've been up to
since you've been gone so here is a
here's a brief little rundown for you
ela
and you can tell me what you think okay
okay all right
it's friday baby let's
57 double quarter powder with cheese
meals
oh euthanize ian won't put you to death
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god you [ __ ] monster oh
god that was so gross thank you guys
i think she's great and i respect her
hustle
you guys trying to get me in trouble
yeah
become a terrorist can you come to me
pitching me
logan paul who are you texting dan
people
people die from suicide from
all those things i agree i think it's a
it's a decent yeah because i think
i don't have the same opinion on poker
stream maybe if you uh
knew that you would you could turn
around and say i'm a [ __ ] hypocrite
for that
i'm giving
everyone's
[Music]
all i wanted was to pitch a camper
outside your house and get
and for you to hook me up with all your
young female friends
not necessarily saying under the age of
18 but close
[Music]
[Music]
ethan literally every one of my ideas
was horrible it's really hard not to get
cancelled
without eli here you did it though
oh so so yeah we kind of actually
for the first time ever ela went to
israel
and i didn't get embroi embroidered in a
major controversy
yeah so thank you anything to say
i was very proud of you thank you keep
it up yeah
thank you thank you thank you although
well that's
half true and that you're being sued
by ryan cavanaugh yeah what's the deal
ryan
so ryan cavanaugh oh well
can you get a life i would wish she
would get i wish she would just run his
business instead of trying to show us
like he must be desperate for cats yeah
i mean i can give him a little tour
a little run down on how to run a
business do it that could be good in the
settlement
you hear that right kevin you can get uh
you can get business advice from a real
ceo
yeah because actually personally i
wouldn't have time to mess around with
some stupid lawsuit but i guess you have
a lot of time
yeah you bring that over here thank you
baby yeah i mean and also
unlike brian cavanaugh you attempt to
make your money through actually
selling products and not suing people
no legitimate products and we pay our
taxes pay our taxes
well i don't know if he pays his taxes
or not i mean i'm just saying we're
doing everything as legitimate as
possible
oh yeah oh yeah and i don't know if you
got this memo
but that so apparently oh oh we pay our
employees
um yeah if you you maybe heard about
ryan's bankruptcy yeah sometimes
it doesn't always pay people yeah oh
there's a lot there's like a thousand
debtors from the bankruptcy but i don't
know if you heard
that ryan cavanaugh this man here was
accused by his ex-partner of running a
ponzi scheme so that's
interesting yeah it's so awkward but
anyway let me get actually into this
believe that was reported in variety
just for clarification right
yeah yeah variety magazine so here's
what i'm going to say
all right how was that to feel like all
of a sudden the lawyers are like
uh don't panic but uh so triller is
suing
you and teddy fresh no it was like what
how
why what do they want i literally have
nothing to do with them
yeah and you can here i'm gonna pull up
i was trying to tell my family about it
and they're like but why and i was like
i s
i have no idea it makes no sense well
okay it the only way it actually makes
sense is when you consider that they're
just
maliciously harassing us yeah but that's
what i'm saying like
does he not have a life i mean i
wouldn't have time for petty stuff like
that
well he's trying to intimidate us to
shutting up
or paying up but again ryan kavanagh
really i don't know who he thinks he's
[ __ ] with like that's just not
my i would never do that i will never
either bring it on in fact the opposite
is true i'm just going to turn
everything into content
wait till you see this complaint okay so
they issued a new they filed an
additional lawsuit to the copyright one
yeah and this is fantastic the fact that
they even
uh filed this is amazing so
here we go and this is it from triller
llc so this isn't even like weird fight
like this is ryan's business okay now
look at this [ __ ]
they they include these amazing
screenshots
look at this this is actually in their
complaint oh my god
this is so dumb wait till you wait to
you and analyze so he goes he's his
whole thing is like
this is war h3 podcast we're going to
war
foot soldiers assemble um what's the
date on this
oh january january 29th
when was the [ __ ] fight when was it
oh yeah exactly i didn't even catch that
when was the fight tell me that oh thank
you we got mud and halva
nice when was the fight somebody told me
the date of the fight the broadcast
what do you what was it the logan no
it's jake paul versus uh
fight was a disaster april 17
april 17th i'm not a mathematician
wow but i'm pretty sure oh my god this
[ __ ] screenshot
oh my god gotcha
got your hat i'm pretty [ __ ] sure
that january 29th
is before april april
again not a mathematician no we'll have
to let the lawyers prove that
you know yeah they're get the lawyers
they'll need to subpoena the calendar
exactly the whole [ __ ] thing about
lawsuits is like they're gonna have to
now prove like
well your honor if you start
chronologically from the beginning of
the year
and count the days you will find it's
like you have to do
proof for everything
so again ryan nice [ __ ] try douche
maybe you should try paying the people
you bankrupted instead of actually
trying to
go after us trying to think but nothing
happens actually you know what they
should do is try to improve
triller because i've been hearing
they're getting a lot of one stars i
hear it's flipped
it's yeah and that's from someone who
they pay
flips oh so
awkward here i have a i have a bunch of
the
main excerpts but i just want to show
you guys the memes
this is another meme they included what
they're taking
to meme they're taking memes from the
subreddit oh my god
it's like this is mad cost 2.0 it
totally is first
no it's matt in the deposition ethan had
to define what a meme is 100
this is repeating it's matt haas with
money it's totally matthaus 2. oh my god
so they go by the way i've never even
seen this meme i don't know where
they're
going is who cares yeah i think it was
on the sub yeah
there was a lot of them but i don't
think this was like a major i mean they
put
honest in quotes because it's a direct
quote that you wanted
them to give an honest review i don't
see how this is evidence of anything
yeah
it's like this you can't make a legal
claim where you
be like this isn't what he said but this
is what he meant that doesn't [ __ ]
work that way
dude i want you to give a trip
to give triller an honest review exactly
that's what i said honest thanks for
quoting it
here's what they say but can you imagine
that they're actually giving shout outs
to our subreddit users
i guess it's cool but they they actually
think we're responsible for what's
posted on
on reddit yeah
i mean it's insanity yeah it's amazing
it's hard to believe
well i'm having a heart a less and less
hard time believing the things that
happened from this guy
well the thing that really pissed us off
is that before they filed this lawsuit
we were entered into what me and our
attorneys thought was good
faith negotiations to end the lawsuit
yeah we were both like let's just let's
end this let's figure it out
and we were in a good faith conversation
this pathetic [ __ ]
wanted to come on our show
i didn't know you wanted to reveal that
it's too late
matt hoss wanted to do the same thing
i'm just saying matt haas wanted to do
the same thing
you should let him step in the lines
then i'm still crowder says yeah i'm
still in shock
that that really happens ryan cavanaugh
wanted to come on the show and talk to
me
doesn't that just show that ulterior
motives i mean he's
just just wants to use this platform for
publicity yeah he wants to promote chile
we got nothing to talk to you bro
but anyway i said no i don't want to
you've already proven you have no
life so what would we talk to you about
just go back
well i would ask him about the ponzi
scheme
yeah oh that would actually be nice
right i would ask about
um
there's some really interesting court
filings we found about the bankruptcy
where he bankrupted a couple times right
well i
i would ask him about him that he didn't
pay her like a hundred thirty thousand
dollars he sniffed the nanny
like that he got sued for left to him
can you pull that up since we're talking
about it
there's some really interesting court
filings we found in a video we're
planning it would be a great interview
actually
but we found some really interesting
court filings one of which
is really [ __ ] interesting i mean we
dug deep ryan
let me just say this cav cav you know
what that means ryan
[Music]
[Laughter]
you should be scared of the knowledge i
have could ruin it man
cap cav coming for you cab cab let me
just say this about cav cav
in minecraft we're coming for you in
minecraft with peace and love
gonna add that to the last that's
allegedly allegedly coming for you
in minecraft your honor this clearly is
a threat
yeah i'm sorry which document am i
looking for oh the nanny's suing him
got it yeah so this is the kind of guy
who stiffs his [ __ ] nanny
do you guys know what saints nannies are
oh yeah i mean that like the most
important job night nurse
in a person's life i mean to me my nanny
is the most important person to me
obviously excuse me sorry but nanny is
your world
like out of like anyone that you pay for
yeah
if your podcast producer is sitting
right here sorry everyone but you know
she's not theodore all day no you're
right the nanny's
like the the responsibilities is crazy i
think it means he doesn't love his kid
are we stiffing his nanny
by the transfer property right
the math checks out the math checks out
and dan i do believe is a uh
as the authority on this one
oh i don't know that thumbnail's pretty
intense cam
well let's talk about it after the show
hey i was over here i was over there
helping him
uh what was the explanation on this
again it's made of sesame
like tell me if that tastes healthy to
you then i mean is it supposed to be
no either thinks it's healthy well it's
like it's pretty sweet
it's like a healthy it's pure fat it's
sesame fat
it's like healthy fat though that's true
i mean it could be
just because it's full of fat doesn't
mean it's unhealthy that said it doesn't
taste healthy
here uh well go ahead ela
read your findings i don't know go ahead
and read it
halva increases the body's protection
against chronic diseases such as
cancer heart and premature aging well
it's going to de-age me
oh it's sick load up it's just alva
it does everything anyway it's like uh
the most classic israeli i think a
middle eastern in general
i really like it because it's like
hummus it's like you use the tahina
and everything the hummus the candies
yeah it's the same [ __ ] but anyway let's
focus
no you lose in the real world in the
trenches doing how the research
it's you can get it from and i think you
can buy it here too by the way if people
want yeah you can buy it
you can buy it and this coffee is great
too oh i didn't try the coffee
do you guys like the smell of it it's
like yeah pretty cool
this oh it's like this i've had before
and this this stuff's bomb
it's really good it's spiced or
something yeah
hell hell it's for help
that's funny that that was that was
speaking of brian kelly's
speaking of ryan kavanagh and hell
imagine being this guy
hollywood executive well ex-executive he
bankrupted his business
sued by babysitter and wage spat it's
not just a babysitter she's a night
nurse
that's when you have a newborn baby and
they take care of the baby at night
it's such an important job they take
care of your newborn baby
here hollywood producer not anymore and
financier not anymore
he's being sued by a former babysitter
for his newborn child who alleges she
is owed more than 175 000 now you may
ask yourself that's a lot of money
but here's why he abruptly fired her in
2020 only two months into her 13-month
contract
now the deal with these night nurses is
that they have to set aside
time for one specific client
because it's hard to find my family and
they're they're they're like transient
they go because when the baby gets
bigger you move on to a new family so
it's hard to find employment
it's not that it's hard to find they're
actually usually really
um they have there's a lot of need for
them but
they'll sometimes stay with the family
like between six months
to like here they wanted her for 13
months
so they have to secure their job every
time afterwards so they get booked up
you know exactly
and they decline work when they have a
contract exactly so it really screws
them
to fire them but you would think so like
in the contract it's like if you fire me
you owe me a certain amount of money
because obviously she settle side and
turn down work to come work for you
so when i was like 175 000 how does that
work well let me explain to you how that
works
this [ __ ] guy
he he in the contract she was going to
work 12
hours a day
at 40 dollars an hour that's how
so he [ __ ] her good yeah
[Music]
yeah i mean imagine not paying like a
working-class person
uh as when you're like apparently a
billionaire i mean hello
this guy cares about people and wait
till you hear about the other [ __ ]
kavkav
god i want to say i don't know if we're
ready to talk about it yet but there's
like
such good stuff i mean this is like
super villain [ __ ]
and this was written down by a judge so
when i say it i say it with full
authority
i know he likes beard too or likes
alcohol like his uh like the other
kavanagh
we'll get into that too we drank beer do
you like beer senator
having some beers with friends turns out
he has the kavanaugh's have a lot in
common
they like beer center you like beer
senator
do you like beer mr cavanaugh we drank
beer we drank beer
so anyway so then the other thing
so this is how they're suing teddy fresh
ela
yeah they go please explain yeah okay so
this is how they justify this and some
absolute alternate universe
legal alternate universe upon
information and belief
yadda yadda there exists a unity of
interest between defendants
individually or separate between and has
i don't know what the [ __ ] all that
means
ted entertainment and teddy fresh are
the alter egos of mr and mrs klein
uh ted entertainment and teddy fresh are
and at all relevant times they're saying
they're shell companies
instrumentalities and conduits through
which mr and mrs klein
carry on business in the name of uh
teddy
entertainment teddy fresh while
exercising complete control and
dominance over them
their business and assets to such an
extent
that our individuality or separateness
between them
on one hand mr and mrs klein on the
other hand do not exist
teddy fresh and entertainment were
conceived intended and used by mr mrs
klein as a device
to avoid liability and for the purpose
of substituting
an under capitalized entity namely teddy
fresh and tan entertainment in the place
of mr mrs cline
ted entertainment teddy fresh are at all
times hearing mentioned were so at
inadequately capitalized which by the
way
i guess they have like a clairvoyant or
something
because i'm not sure where they're
getting this information from like a
psychic
oh i think they consulted a crystal ball
on this
so inadequately inadequately capitalized
that comparing
the business done by mr mrs klein and
the risk of loss
their capitalization was illusionary and
trifling
in addition many assets of teddy fresh
were transferred without adequate
consideration
to mr mrs klein mr mrs klein diverted
assets
from teddy fresh to themselves to suit
their own convenience in carrying out
business matters
which were and should have been the
domain of teddy fresh
teddy fresh are and at all times hearing
mentioned control dominated and operated
by them
as alter egos in that the activities and
businesses of teddy fresh were carried
out without annual meetings
and without keeping records or minutes
of any proceedings or maintaining
written
uh uh resolutions sorry what yeah
exactly so they're saying adhering to
the fiction of this
this separate entities is ryan
projecting i mean is that how he does
business
he must be totally projecting this is
definitely written
or it's just an outer ego i mean that's
kind of like
an artistic way to look at it but it's a
legal claim
but like you have to have intimate
knowledge of the company's finances to
make such a claim and of course he
doesn't know anything
it's not that hard to find anything
about teddy fresh it's all
i mean it's as legit as you can get and
what what did they want this is so dumb
the co-mingling of assets and unlawful
business conducts and other accusing us
of breaking the law
as alleged here fully within by defense
was intended among other things
to allow mr and mrs client to avoid
liability to the plaintiffs
so basically they're saying these
companies are fake
and we're using them to hide assets from
ryan kavanaugh
teddy fresh exists for the purpose of
hiding assets
from ryan kavanaugh
yeah an alter ego would be for example
let's say ryan kavanaugh
company went bankrupt okay what was the
company of his that went bankrupt
is relativity media so let's say well
this isn't hypothetical this happened
let's say he bankrupts his company
relativity media
yeah that did happen but let's say ryan
cavanaugh sets up like
a another company called i don't know
ryan
is um
you know ryan triller is a one-star app
llc and ryan moves like
a bunch of money from the bankrupted
relativity media to
triller's a one star app llc yeah and
then he goes well
or sorry incorporate it so be like look
i'm incorporated over here
at triller's a one star app and
and so i'm not liable well that would be
an alter ego because
it's not a real the company is is not
really doing business
it's just it's like a sham company yeah
to shield from liability
right because part of what a corporation
does is it protects the owners from
liability
if they were to get sued or something
you know but
what this is so stupid yeah it's insane
well they just pulled it out of thin air
because it's obviously all
super untrue i don't have meetings what
was that about no he's j they're lying i
mean they're making [ __ ] up it's insane
they
because they can't file the complaint
based on nothing so they're just
lying out of thin air we're we're
carried out without annual meetings
and without keeping your records sorry
yeah no they're
they're exactly they have to say this
but they have no
information they're lying they're just
lying to intimidate you
they're going after you elo all right
now here i pulled up our favorite
moments
um that i'll read to you
so it's like i mean this is the legal
system guys you can just lie
about [ __ ] and that's what it is so here
you go
[Music]
the scare quotes surrounding the word
honest utterly belie
any defense that this post encourages
legitimate users of the app to leave
good faith reviews based upon their
actual oh they misspelled experiences
dumb asses
defendants social media activity
established an overwhelming
record to the contrary bro what is i
want you to give triller an honest
review and i still
do well we didn't make this post i
didn't make this post so
what even are we talking about exactly
they don't understand the internet
they're just they think i'm an idiot
they think we're stupid as [ __ ] and they
can intimidate us
and let me be very clear i still want
you
all of you to give an honest review to
trailer
that's still that's still something i'm
passionate about
you know and no air quotes
i'm not doing this i want you to give an
honest
this is the opposite of airplane honest
review of trailer
no air quotes i'm honest
honestly yeah yeah by the way our lawyer
said that um not that i did this but
he's like if he wanted to
you could straight up say everybody go
to triller and give them a one star
and that would be free speech protected
i didn't do that though
i didn't even do that uh did you
okay so here's another one to detract
attention from the copyright action
and in a deeply misguided attempt to
exact revenge for the copyright action
and to gain an unfair advantage in the
highly competitive entertainment
industry
what am i competing against them now
what does that mean
so so the this other lawsuit which is
called uh
[ __ ] i remember i forget what it is but
they're saying we're getting an
unfair competitive advantage against
trailer i'm not a competitor to trailer
you [ __ ] idiot
oh maybe they found out about ethan's
feet that's kind of a social media
[ __ ] yeah love damn it you're
screwing us
up you guys can just tell them to sue me
instead
yeah sue love i don't i don't even get
any of that merch money that's all love
he's coming for your hundred dollars in
merch money love you better [ __ ] hide
that
you better make a new company oh there
you go that [ __ ]
wait wait wait hundred dollars how much
did you make
be honest 376
you better all-star ego that [ __ ] fast
did you see the emergency
selling no oh yeah i'm taking this money
i'm i'm gonna dip
you're gonna you're gonna rub pole rut
pull the rug out on ethan's feet
so love made ethan's feet you know about
ethan's feet right yeah
guys don't go here it's going to crash
please oh my god maybe i might have
updated the service i'm not sure
uh oh it's not loading [ __ ] every time
okay here it is take it for life
oh you have made from merch on the
[ __ ] home page
70 000 side views that's pretty good 25
plus merch sales dude you are
[ __ ] you are so made bro
well wait til you see them it's actually
the worst merch i've ever seen i hate it
so well this just says ethan's feet.com
but wait did you see this design
cameron made this for for love cameron
are you getting any kickbacks on this
yeah this is the worst thing i've ever
seen you're doing everything i need to
text before
i send it to cam oh oh yeah that's for
sure
that is fair make sure to make sure to
make a shell company called ryan
cavanaugh runs a one-star
review what was that country called that
the gambling site was on
carousel you could definitely set up a
shell company
i'm just wondering
yeah anyway this is funny so
congratulations everybody
on the all the merch cells love is
crushing it with ethan's feet he saw an
opportunity he took it man that's what i
like about him
it crashed yeah it's crashed
all right [ __ ] i'm having so much fun
all right let's thank our our sponsors
and ryan cavanaugh no you cannot
get a cut of this
i'm having trouble finding my monitor
here it is all right let's do uh we have
two sponsors real fast let's give him a
quick shout out and then we'll get right
back to it
hello mother loving fresh
i love hello fresh with hellofresh you
get fresh pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
door
skip trips to the grocery store you can
count on hellofresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable and
that's why it's america's number one
meal cake you see that beautiful that's
the that's the one that
ian and sam cooked up and how did you
guys like it ian
oh it was really good yeah very good sam
was going wild about it
i believe she said quote it was bomb
um listen get better
value with hellofresh it's 28 cheaper
than shopping at your local grocery
store and 72 percent cheaper than a
restaurant meal
without sacrificing any of the quality
um
i'm trying to find mine hellofresh
offers flexibility you need to easily
customize your order on the app within
minutes
you can change your delivery date food
preferences plant size or skip a week
whenever you want
hellofresh is all about stress field
stress free meal planning and grocery
store
trips with less prep less effort and
minimal clean up so you can enjoy
the experience of cooking get dinner on
the table in 30 minutes
and have that bomb ass meal without any
of the fuss
right you know i love hell fresh it's
fun
you get the joy of cooking you don't
have to worry about oh i gotta get the
ingredients but
i'll get the fresh it's always good
ingredients it's it's by bam it's the
joy of cooking and all the [ __ ] out
and also we've got a great offer for you
guys go to hellofresh.com
slash h3 after dark 14 and use code
after dark 14
the code for up to 14 free meals
plus free shipping so once again that's
hellofresh.com
after doug 14 use code after dark 14 for
14 free meals baby clarify that url
because you said it wrong the first
dark hellofresh.com you threw an h3 in
there and gave me a little mini heart
attack hellofresh.com14 afterdark14
hellofresh.com
it's also on screen and in the
description thank you thank you thank
you peace and love
um anyway guys listen it's hella fresh
america's number one meal kit
enjoy and thank you just for sponsoring
us and finally we have appstart
we love you upstart so many americans
experience financial hardship this year
and upstart
can help you regain your footing and get
things back on track
upstart is the fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debts or funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used up
start to get one
fixed monthly payment upstart knows
you're more than just your credit score
and it's expanding access to affordable
credit
unlike other lenders upstart considers
your income and current employment
to find you a smarter rate for your loan
within a five minute online rate check
you can see your rate
upfront for loans between 1 000 to 50
000
you can receive funds as fast as one
business day
after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payment today when you go to
upstart.com
slash after dark that's upstart.com
after dark and don't forget to use our
url to let them know
we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application
remember guys that's
upstart.com after dark thank you
[Music]
all right thank you thank you peace and
love
back to ryan cavanaugh
[Laughter]
so he goes uh to to detract attention
from the copyright action
and in a deeply misguided attempt to
exact revenge
for the copyright action and to gain an
unfair advantage and highly competitive
entertainment industry
see the thing is their their charges are
so loose they have these
absolutely um anemic char these
it's not even anemic it's like just
wrong
it's like you can only sue it for for
this competitive thing it's like we're
not competitives dude
defendants mr and mrs klein teddy fresh
and does to refresh and does one two
uh one to five hundred announced they're
going to war
with certain affiliates of fight club
the [ __ ] is dude
are those one to five hundred i'm not
sure but are they referring to this post
from january 29th
because that is not good legal
we drink beer we drink beer
so we're going to war they say threes is
this exhibit three
i guess it doesn't say here but i mean
i'm assuming that's what they're
referring to
with certain affiliates of fight club
including triller
and ryan cavanaugh and furtherance of
that war
defendants specifically instructed their
rabid fans
come on you guys known as foots guys
they're insulting
our fans now they're insulting yeah you
called you guys rabid fans you are
rabbits that's too far that's that's no
no no
you guys are not rabid absolutely not if
anyone's rabbit it's ryan kavanagh for
money
god um he doesn't pay his own nightmares
leave thousands of negative so-called
troll reviews
for triller's uh app
well i mean if they're leaving reviews
i'm assuming it's because your app is
bad
right you know and it's flipped if your
[ __ ] wasn't flipped yeah maybe if your
[ __ ] maybe your reviews will be
you can flip that review score i mean if
it wasn't if it wasn't flipped yeah
you probably like i find it iron i find
it very funny ryan kavanaugh
that somehow your app getting bad
reviews is my fault
all i've said is to leave honest reviews
my thing's flipped and that's what
people are doing
and they're not rabid [ __ ]
defendants have advanced their schemes
via various social media platforms
including but not limiting to
defendant's dedicated form on reddit.com
shout out
shout out h3 productions on reddit a
popular social news aggregator the h3
subreddit
upon information belief defendants and
or sub sub defendants employees moderate
and thereby control the posts
you guys are being blamed for this one
you didn't delete
they're literally crying to the mods
yeah
why don't you guys just send a report in
the subreddit yeah i mean dan underscore
h3 that's my uh username on reddit uh
if you have a problem with the post take
it up with the mods right
via the official channels
brian's just mad because he got banned
they're listing people's comments
yeah yo yo they give shout outs to posts
look you guys
for example in may 2021 reddit user our
conversational actual 77 shout out
shout out bro shout out to his family
posted to this take down triller let's
all rate trailer a one
on the app store for being greedy little
[ __ ] first of all i don't condone that
if you give them a one let it be because
you don't like the app but we have no
say on what people
comment on reddit yeah i'm surprised
they don't include uh
posts on like 4chan subreddit about
you know something else it's like oh
well oh
another sh well i'm just saying well
what why not blame us for everything
bad posted on reddit while you're out
there yeah
uh another shout out on july 2nd
reddit user 2 poke us2
shout out posted to the issue foot
soldier's time
to bank down triller app called by the
king himself bank down
what does that mean i'm too old to know
that one
well i don't know sorry i can't i
actually can't
wait because i don't know what bank down
means explain so when he says called by
the king himself i don't know
what that if this gets to trial you
should you should ask them if they know
what that means yeah
because i don't i mean i didn't post it
so i can't read his mind
for all i know ryan cavanaugh posted
this to try to frame me
ooh don't don't put that on
to poke us too yeah it's true
on july 8th another shout out don't
blame me 13
posters of the h27 foot soldiers
assemble take the triller app
we can do better than this hey listen
listen if that's what they want to do
that's between them i didn't ask anyone
to tank the trailer app
with a one star rating
upon information and belief this is a
a substantial precedent for defendant's
foot soldier brigading websites on
defendant's command
uh-oh indeed approximately one year ago
business insider reported that old spice
dropped its sponsorship of h3h
among the brewing troll war with
keemstar whoa
whoa whoa they're actually trying to
gain sympathy
i did not see that that's incredible
[Laughter]
there was a conspiracy theory that
keemstar was feeding him
my dirt and then this kind of supports
that like in what world would they bring
up
keemstar being dropped can't wait all
spies
and sponsorship
reported following a spat with mr klein
and keemstar
it's like a romeo julia went over
to produce a video about keemstar title
content nuke
great video by the way yeah yeah check
it out
keem did they really refer to him as
keem
that's his real name isn't it his last
name daniel oh no his last name is keem
okay
yeah no that's okay yeah keemstar shut
up
shut up
content nuke that accused keem of lying
about klein committing fraud
right yeah it did i think what they're
trying to do
is put like my dirty laundry quote
unquote and
public finally but you don't really get
to do that do you
it's completely unrelated it is totally
unrelated that's like
so frustrating i think it's a good thing
if you're worth a billion dollars in the
like all the dirt you can find is like
keemstar [ __ ] like
it's pretty sad you're pretty squeaky
lying about me
i have a feeling they're in contact bro
because this
is just so out of luck it makes noise
yeah so he goes
um climb went on to produce a video
about keemstar called contact nuke the
accused keemstar of lying about client
committing fraud
and additionally compiled examples of
keem's offensive behavior including a
controversial interview with the tubular
a youtuber who would later die by
suicide right why would you where team
appeared to suggest jumping off a bridge
that's [ __ ] insane why are you
including that that actually seems like
so inappropriate to bring that into this
i'm like really sick
it doesn't it's so irrelevant it yeah
i mean the goal is to make you look bad
by citing
when you went after somebody yeah for
like a really good reason
but i think they're just trying to make
it look make me look like a messy person
or something i don't know
but they're using kit edica's suicide
for no [ __ ] reason they're saying
it's bad that you called him out for
doing that
it's like what in what universe does
that help their
case against you they said business
insider further reported that after
content
nuke debuted g-fuels long-time sponsor
of keemstar
were spammed with comments asking for
the energy drink company to end its
sponsorship of keem
sounds like they had a pretty good
reason to do that
like and and equally i would even say
it sounds like people leaving a one-star
review of triller have a pretty good
reason to be doing that
sure because they don't like that why
not because they need to get that [ __ ]
flipped free speech
garbage it's just they need to unflip
their ass i need to unflip their app
[Laughter]
it's so simple yo can you blink me that
note the no back i want to watch that
yo trailer
defendants go on to incite their foot
soldiers
ex exhorting them by saying i'll be
checking in
on the trailer reviews and asking that
foot soldiers try the app
listen to this this is the best they
have okay listen
this is evidence try the app
see how it goes and give it a one star
or
more laughter
one or more stars some amount of stars
between one star
and up to maybe five stars download
triller and rate it one star
or more that's what i do
that's evidence of me trying to take
their app
it literally is me being partial
i call that evidence of a sense of humor
exactly your honor you click
this is not legal argument by the way
saying your honor you know what they
meant
okay that's not legal argument you know
what they meant your honor
imagine the judge being like but was it
funny yeah
and you've only mentioned the app store
to give a fair review correct if i'm not
only ever i mean this is all they have
this is the worst thing okay well if you
look up triller app review
there's about five other websites that
all have a lower rating
than the app store oh really the app
store is actually the highest
anyone could google that and there's
like four other websites app review
oh that's well let's do that yeah send
me the they're in the discord
oh great that's that's really
interesting
so you're saying to the contrary
that the one they're what they're
claiming is that i tank their
their app store review but clearly if
you look at it on
other apps it has a way lower rating so
like how
can i have tanked it if that's their
highest rated spot
correct perhaps the foot soldiers
actually increase their score
so this is like a this is like a media
review of trailer
by an app review by nelly johnson
if you scroll down there's comments
three stars
parents say one star kids say four stars
okay
so somewhere between one and four stars
see i was even more generous
yeah you said one and five so maybe you
encouraging the audience to give a fair
review
help them out right maybe they should
hire you
how can they draw that distinction that
i'm causing one stars when this guy gave
it a three star
they still have a 4.6 on the app store
by the way noah back on who's being paid
to be on trailer
just a little call back yo trailer
my thing's flipped my camera's like
flipped around right now but look
i'm so i'm trying to uh it's so awkward
because it didn't go hey guys like look
it's when i put it this way
oh i see it yeah weird it's like
mirrored should i head off
i love that great content
so how do they expect five car reviews
when their [ __ ] is flipped
like even their people they're paying to
be on there can't say nice things about
them
oh it's so awkward
good call good uh catch baby yeah
there's more websites in there
and then i sent three different ones
let's see i i i wouldn't just tell me
what the ratings are
i don't need to look at everything okay
let me just go back and check
i mean here appgrooves.com let's see
what they gave them
a 4.5 oh that's oh is that the app store
on google play
whatever i'm over it no this is an app
review 2.2 out of
two 5. five you see
anyway um
download trailer give it a once although
defendants state that we do not condone
okay so again
although defendants did state that we do
not condone
and we do not encourage troll reviews
defendants visible and audible laughter
while making the aforementioned
statement
coupled with defendant's promotion of
various supposed troll reviews
who's to define who's to decide what's a
troll review and what's a serious review
this seriously is like this is so crazy
it's so bad this really this is this is
like
discord mod drama like the way that this
is all structured
more than like a legal complaint this is
somebody crying to the mods on reddit
about how they got banned unfairly yeah
right
first of all yeah it's all like
basically their whole argument is judge
judge you can read between the lines
yeah that's not how the law that's not a
lawsuits work we don't read between the
lines
so they're saying yes he said we do not
condone and we do not encourage but they
were laughing
they're not allowed to laugh when they
say that they were mean
they were so mean to me according to
triller every one star review is a troll
review
um anyway we'll be back every episode to
review the reviews reveals defendant's
true motivation to inspire foot soldiers
to leave troll reviews indeed
just seconds after reporting to disavow
troll reviews defendants joke about
their foot soldiers would never brigade
us website on their command there's no
precedent for that
how did we get that name again it's
funny because he still hasn't figured
that out
you still haven't explained why we're
called foot soldiers [ __ ] to show
keemstar and the videos defendants make
false misleading and
malicious statements concerning triller
mr kavanaugh including
that triller is and mr kavanaugh run a
ponzi scheme
excuse me i never [ __ ] said that
your ex business partner is the one that
said that buddy
as reported in variety magazine uh
leading trade paper in the entertainment
industry it's [ __ ] excuse me [ __ ]
i never said that you run a ponzi scheme
oh listen to this one that triller
falsely represented that comedian kevin
hart uses the app
well you're the one that wrote it
where's his [ __ ] account
and by the way they updated their
[ __ ] they removed it from the
description
kevin hart so clearly my feedback was of
some use to you
show me can you link me the new
description yeah it's in the dark out
here let me
say i defamed them
because kevin hart doesn't use the hat
well we're giving art on your outfit
it clearly said that kevin hart used the
app
and i checked last night and they
updated the copy
to remove kevin hart's name so where's
my [ __ ] money for helping improve
your dumb ass app
amazing the original description was
create share connect with global
superstars such as josh richards
charlie demilia no back kevin hart tyga
and more
well guess what their copy don't say
that no more
look
where's kevin hart they removed it great
share with josh richard
uh charlie d'amilia noah beck and tyga
where's kevin hart why'd you remove it
why'd you remove it
why the [ __ ] did you remove it and i
defamed you
no you you defamed me i lied to me that
kevin hart was on your app
true that's false advertising i
downloaded triller
because i'm a huge fan of kevin hart and
i wanted to see him on your [ __ ] app
you defamed me you [ __ ] lied to me
and maybe that's why i gave you a one
star and other people did too
because kevin hart wasn't on the app
also that listen to this
they're right the app is flipped
defender the malicious statement
saying the app is flat
[Laughter]
i found the original screenshot i have
of the original description
just just know that we have proof just
say approve yeah
here's the original screenshot we took
just so they can't say i lied
what's the name next to noah beck kevin
hart
they said the app is flipped
it is flipped do i need to open noah
back again saying
yo trailer my thing is flipped
the app is flipped they broke that
according to what they wrote mr
cavanaugh bears a physical resemblance
to harvey weinstein
and for the record i always said i
didn't really see it they do yeah i
don't really see it
i don't know a lot of people disagree
have to republican
that i disagree a lot of people feel
differently but i i just
i don't see it i don't see it are you
gonna call this defamation
i'm allowed to say you look like harvey
weinstein
yes harvey weinstein's a notorious
convicted sexual predator are you
self-reporting
i said you look alike
starting to look closer and closer the
more i look at it it they're so
similar looking
[Laughter]
the vincent's defendants also state mr
kavanaugh is suing them mr cavanaugh
never sued defendants
well he does own triller and the lawyer
literally said to us kavanaugh's behind
this
lawsuit and also why are you upset then
if you're not suing me that you said
you're including in here that mr
kavanaugh bears a physical resemblance
to harvey weinstein
if you're not suing me if you're not
involved in this lawsuit then why is it
all about you
you're telling you don't see the
resemblance i didn't
at first but i'm starting to it's
growing
and like i'm starting to see what you're
talking about thank you yeah
the chat's saying do a poll that's a
good idea i mean let's just be fair
let's be fair
but you could find out for yourself
let's decide yeah they can add a
screenshot of the poll now i'm allowed
to have an opinion about what he looks
like he'd say you look like mary [ __ ]
poppins it's not defamation
it's my opinion [ __ ]
let's do it are you working on her love
doing it baby's got it okay all right
guys cast your vote
does ryan kavanagh
have a physical resemblance to harvey
weinstein
yes or no yes or no
any resemblance at all it doesn't need
to be identical just any resemblance at
all
i'm setting it up give it a second the
poll is going up now
harvey weinstein convicted predator
oh do you think ryan is gonna vote he's
voting no he's probably watching
he's voting no he's sending it to
everyone in his whatsapp right now vote
no vote no
[Laughter]
all right i've pinned the poll right i'm
also spamming him doesn't mean you did
his crime
i am spamming the poll right now all
right guys let's see
um and here i will pull it up here we go
and i am going to
place my vote right now
way down it's okay here we go and i want
everyone to be honest oh
no yeah okay let's see the results
oh my vote's been counted all right so
the results we'll see the results
it's a big moment you click it nothing's
happening i think it's going
slow are we cracking strawball again no
no
get your votes in we [ __ ] crashed
straw poll that's insane you guys yeah i
guess we shouldn't hear you well people
are passionate they want to get their
votes in
i could give you where it was at have it
323.00
okay oh here okay
but i got it i got to show it on screen
yeah it's very so you
i've never seen such a conclusive poll
before in my life
i've never seen such a conclusion can
you try refreshing dan he just
he just did i have never
seen such a conclusion maybe you try to
open a result ever
you hold this then okay guys we asked
does ryan cavanaugh have a
physical resemblance to harvey weinstein
you guys took the poll and you
sent your answers the results are in
we've crashed the site people are
passionate straight up we can't get
i can send a screenshot i think yes
obviously
you want to just read off the result no
okay here it is
95 yes
i have never in all of my life
and all of my life doing struggles
have seen the result 95
of 6 500 ballads cast
ryan don't feel bad five percent a lot
five percent is every five percent is
everything five percent it just comes up
again and again that means everything
maybe straw poll is another alter-ego
company of ours yeah we own trouble
but like to say that mr kavanaugh bears
a physical resemblance to harvey
weinstein to say that that's false and
misleading
and malicious how dare you 95
but the best part of course is that the
trailer is flipped
the app is flipped is by far
the best thing in here
the defendants and videos defendants
misrepresent a june 7
variety magazine article and claim that
variety
article supports their statement that
triller is
and mr cavanaugh runs a ponzi scheme
okay back the
[ __ ] up no one ever said triller is a
ponzi i have ever
again another self report yeah i have
never said triller is a ponzi scheme
i gave it a one star
because that's was my experience because
they lied about kevin hart mm-hmm
right misleading false advertising job
rule
gotta rule what do you remember what
where are you
what do you call it when you say kevin
hart's on this app but he's not
i would call that uh false advertising
right
even ja rule and trust me know something
about your falsehoods
how to dig ourselves out of this [ __ ]
man it's not going to be suing elon
definitely not so they said i say
triller's a ponzi scheme why don't you
include the quote then
[ __ ] i never said that
[Laughter]
oh yeah also you're the partner of the
one said you're running a positive
defendant's statement that triller is
and mr kevin
kavanagh runs a ponzi scheme are false
misleading and malicious edges finance
knows
i don't know [ __ ] your partner said it i
don't [ __ ] know false advertising
indeed indeed the variety article
defended per uh
purportedly based their false mis okay
so it's variety's fault
what do you what is it my problem
variety article
uh purportedly based their false
misleading and malicious statements upon
neither
mentions nor references triller well
neither did i
yeah where are they getting this we
never they're picking it up
they're making it up it's a flat out
[ __ ] lie
and expressly and unambiguously disavows
any claims regarding a ponzi scheme okay
great that's between you and [ __ ] god
i'm just quoting your ex-business
partner
as reported by variety public
information yeah
and variety does include the court docs
just i find yeah they have the whole
complaint
let me read it for yourself what the
[ __ ] do i care i never called them a
ponzi scheme but if you're
self-reporting then fine
is is triller a ponzi scheme now i mean
it doesn't even how would it be a ponzi
scheme it doesn't even
on its surface it doesn't make me right
but it's now i'm wondering no other
ponzi scheme
i mean i'm not sure how that would work
but it's so
awkward so it's so awkward
ted entertainment teddy fresh were
conceived intended and this is
the alter ego yeah so our companies were
of were created for the sole purpose of
avoiding liability
and our businesses are under capitalized
somehow how in the future would they
know that
we read this part earlier yeah i know
i'm just yeah how would you
know that my business are under
capitalized you can't even figure out
the base
facts of this case like that i never
said [ __ ]
i never said triller was a ponzi scheme
you freaks
maybe because it's teddy fresh sells out
so quick they're like look there's never
even any merch
maybe
now the reason they're doing it is
because once again they think we're
morons
and this tactic would maybe work on some
people but when they do the alter ego
it's them setting the road map to go
after your personal assets
so they go oh you're not safe we're
coming for everything but obviously it's
[ __ ] and i know that and
like so they're just again it's just
fear tactics during the july 8th video
mr klein
appears before a background that
contains among other things a review
for the app left by ethan klein right
the review states using trillar has been
one of the worst experiences of my life
i would rather get a colonoscopy from a
chain-link fence over having to use the
software one more time
i would rather get e coli from a dirty
sanchez on the scorching day in death
valley
instead of trying to operate this
tick-tock knockoff ever again
i would rather listen to david dobrik's
luciferian
demon laughter play on a loop as my ears
bleed
it's substituted hellish vlog night
terror
i can't wake up from instead of walking
into the trailer app
also brian cavanaugh was involved in a
ponzi scheme according to his former
business partner allegedly
one star app yes
yes that's my review god i hope they
asked someone to elaborate on what a
dirty sanchez is
in the courtroom yeah if i didn't matter
so this is some of the highlights so
pretty [ __ ] insane
nice thank you for the rundown
i still wouldn't know how to explain it
to my mom when she asked
well it's just it you could just
describe it as a frivolous lawsuit
kriller will probably sue her soon
enough yeah no one in your family is
safe
they're gonna disturb theodore yeah
apparently the relationship with your
mom is an alter ego right
the height of assets do break
dubrick dubrick
dubrick dubrick
anyway so cool
so that's it welcome back you're being
sued thanks
and i would once again wrap this up by
saying
i encourage all of you watching and
listening to give chiller
an honest review of your experience make
sure you do that why not you get it
oh yeah not that when i say honest i'm
not doing [ __ ] air quotes
honest fully on this is me saying fully
honest
no air quotes no laughter okay
try to transcribe this no laughing oh
god try to transcribe this
no laughter serious as a heart attack
give triller an honest review all of you
honest
honest honest really hard for me not to
laugh
what's funny i'm i just laugh at
everything sorry
you're a happy person you're gonna sue
me for that is that illegal to be happy
yeah all right
well ryan i don't know what to tell you
back to my first
statement why don't you get a life mad
house 2.0
yeah yeah she's right though you on the
wrong street cuz
that's right wait just i mean i would
show him a day in my life working on
teddy fresh but i would not waste my
time on that so
well he wants to come on the show so
yeah that's not happening
he got he got mad when i said no start
your own podcast
brah called the called the i was accused
by my partner and variety of running a
ponzi scheme podcast
haha [ __ ] i'm laughing cause you big
mad
you know ricegum's still talking [ __ ]
about you too either he is
cheese guys grilled cheese grilled
cheese
yeah i don't know where this guy gets
off he's still mad what's happening
between me and ricegum
nothing he's still just insulting you
for no reason here did we talk about him
i don't even remember i mean i'm always
[ __ ] talking
i think he knew you're out of the
country and you felt safe to talk [ __ ]
again
well he's back now [ __ ] damn
balenciaga never looked worse
yeah oh my god one million last month
yo yeah what is his deal
yo you guys see how excited he is i've
never seen him this excited over his own
girl
his own girl's so [ __ ] boring he fall
asleep bro
like he's looking you've tried yo
you're making yo yo i've never heard him
say yo i'm
his girl be so boring like he just
he like he's looking for something out
he like he like dang out all his
favorite i need to find out more energy
bro his girl is literally bro that girl
talks
like so slowly she talks like this hey
guys today we're
going to you know what i'm saying so he
was talking to a new girl got a little
excited never
i've never seen not from america [ __ ]
idiot
what's your excuse i mean
ricegum doesn't sound that good when he
talks no he's one of the dumbest
sounding people
just based on his i wouldn't go there
but if you want to go there i mean
no i totally agree listen to yourself
well
it's just i find it odd that he goes
ethan's so famous
and he has so much clout i'm surprised
you couldn't get a better it's like i'm
married to the baddest [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] game
self-made millionaire ceo of a [ __ ]
fat quick growing company with what now
like 35 employees
head [ __ ] creative designer [ __ ]
gorgeous
mother this is the baddest [ __ ] in the
game i'm sorry
you don't [ __ ] know what real [ __ ]
looks like and you've never made it more
clear
like i'm sorry dude i got the baddest
[ __ ] and even before i had clout or
fame so what the [ __ ]
you you'd be a virgin if you weren't
didn't have 12 year olds watching you on
twitch
thank you guaranteed this [ __ ]
would never even have touched a tip
before
and that's the only way he understands
relationships is through clout
and fame because he knows he wouldn't he
would never
get any action if he didn't have that to
offer because as a human being he's
completely irredeemable
and he calls me boring like you sound
brain dead
like i would not spend a second with you
also dude you got money get a
septoplasty he needs
his his nostrils are blocked oh you
think that's why
i'm absolutely positive you need a
septoplasty dude
there's more there's a part two
what's this one i reacted to the same
[ __ ] bro i literally saw it out the way
i saw it on the way up
so cool dude you need to get a better
[ __ ]
you can't breathe you can't breathe i'm
telling you guys
the dude can't breathe what a beta can't
even breathe right [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
better nose
i need it i got a septoplasty but i'm
alpha i have an alpha nose bro i can
breathe fine
rice comes such a beta knows
xqc and altar guys
dude this guy's girlfriend's so boring
i've been trying to what does he do
again that's a good question
well he recently he he sells uh
save the kids cryptocurrency uh okay to
people
and um steals a bunch of money from his
fans all right it's one of his latest
activities
um well sorry uh legitimate running
business is boring yeah he doesn't know
what that is what i do all day because
you rely
you run a legitimate business what are
boring
i think that's why he's so stupid i
think he's not getting the right amount
of oxygen to his brain
that's a very bad
he's probably a really nice guy he just
deprived of oxygen
yeah he's great permanently you know
remember that episode where homer had a
crayon in his brain
right and then they dislodged him
because right that's right
yep here's a gucci bag in his brain
so boring i'm so cool
[Laughter]
knows that's [ __ ] he's only ever
had beefs
like real beefs with women he's never he
talks [ __ ] about guys he ran into the
guy from team 10 i forget his name
and he [ __ ] breaks the only person he's
ever gotten beef with and actually
physically touched her
was gabby when he knocked her phone out
of her hand
yeah but to answer your question he
stopped doing youtube because it's too
hard or something i don't know he just
he does like weird i actually don't i'm
not going to comment i don't know what
he does i'm not going to say
like and like does he live with aiden
i'm sorry did you just invite yourself
on my show
like that drama [ __ ] like we talk like
you know i mean that would be crazy
seriously how is this guy criticizing me
no i'm just saying like what is he
talking like he does when he's from
vegas
how was how was being from
like his accent everything it's all fake
it's all about trying to be
moving oh well he does have likes
he does put on like a fake accent right
yeah he's from vegas he's not
yeah i love vegas i'm not talking
yeah but why is he thinking he's coming
on my show how much [ __ ] like we talk
like
i can't get over that he thinks he's got
he's invited on the show that's a
miracle he knows how to stream
he figured that out yeah he probably had
help aiden did it for him
but like dude you think you would be an
interesting guest
i'd rather talk to it i'd rather i'd
rather talk to a chia pet
if he brings a translator maybe he can
go on the ryan cavanaugh show
ryan gavin could have a really riveting
conversation
if i ever go on his [ __ ] like that drama
[ __ ] like we talk like
you know i mean that would be crazy rice
do you have a fantasy about coming on
this show
that was crazy he really wants to come
on this show
that's pretty sad that would just be
toxic though he a hater like a big hit a
big old ass hater with his weak ass
bro his wife is oh my bro don't don't
get me started bro
the devil is my uh what the [ __ ] is this
fit no
i'm fun with it bro people say match the
top
with the bottom you know red on red type
[ __ ]
this is kanye wow he knows colors bro
the kanye mask thing
you guys know that kanye mask thing oh
is that it i think i need to
i love that he wants to come on our show
man that's amazing
it's like the mess looks cool but i
think it'd be even harder for me to
breathe than that
[Laughter]
can you grab a soundbite of him doing
that zach i know it's obscure but just
i'm going
yeah i can look for one sniveling little
turd
so eli you heard about how kanye's not
leaving the stadium
like yeah so he did this whole big show
where he was supposed to premiere his
album
it wasn't finished um
they were apparently recording uh vocals
backstage here is backstage before the
album's supposed to premiere the
recording vocals why does he do this ian
i don't understand like just take the
time
to make that out to finish the [ __ ]
album it's like this is it he keeps
doing this
what is the deal yeah i don't really
know it's
some sort of spontaneous thing hi the
album you said you liked
yay he took the picture that cover photo
he took that
driving to premiere the album like on
the way there he pulled over
and took that picture it's tough
though because i i don't think that
picture is bad you know no i like that
album i like that
one the photos easy the album are
secondary to the
content of the music that you just said
the whole thing was uh
it's it's been a recurring theme you
know
it's very last minute you've said to me
before just speculating
and maybe other people speculate this
too but it kind of makes sense to me i
think that
at this stage in his life him
announcing the album is his way of
motivating himself to actually do it
like if i say i'm going to release an
album
there's going to be the public pressure
to do so
and i actually will be motivated doesn't
it sounds like he actually want to make
music what were we going to say
kind of yeah um the
it's i don't know he's he's like uh
he's one of those artists that are
probably kind of like all over the place
but he's is uh totally in it
you know it's just he used to i feel
like
and you can correct me from wrong and he
used to complete the albums
um yeah yeah i mean back when you had to
put cds in stores you know i think that
was a big thing
you know the label's like we have to
ship a thing
now he can update it streaming you know
change a song change a track it's also
easy there's no physical
stuff anymore so you don't have to
necessarily finish an album now
well at any rate he's staying in the
[ __ ] studio
i don't know why but he says i'm not
leaving this stadium until the album's
done and here he is cruising around in
the same exact
outfit during like a soccer game or
something that happened the next
the next so he's just cruising around
i don't know how he gets that clearance
but there you go
uh here's his living here's his living
quarters
oh no it was removed you guys oh we have
a backup good
nice job guys here's his living quarters
in the uh
looks like a prison but it does get it
done
so anyway i have basically um
something prepared for you ela um is
that
you know since since you've been gone
yeah i've also been living in the studio
so it's a little embarrassing to admit
but i noticed you've been making so much
content
exactly it's a little embarrassing to me
but we do have a video
uh prepared for you so go ahead ian
[Music]
ethan what are you what are you doing
here
hey b what are you doing here i was just
watching
i was just taking a break what is this
family's your united videos what are you
watching are you all right dude
yeah it's military homecoming surprises
i'm just
it just came up on my recommended pages
it has nothing to do with anything
dude how long have you been here are you
staying here i don't know since
friday friday yeah dude this isn't good
man you need to get out
i was just staying and working on the
podcast i just wanted to make sure
that it was perfect you want some
doritos man no i don't want dude
ethan this is this is bad man i'm
worried i'm worried
i'm going to walk around the fog drivers
i just want to make sure the podcast is
perfect i don't understand which is a
big deal i
i'm committed to the crap i'm going to
make sure it's burglary have you fed the
dogs
yeah doritos they like the rails
i'm going to call dan i'll i'll be right
back i don't see what's the big deal man
can't i can't eat there he doesn't sleep
in the office for three days
captain crunch [ __ ] this
hey dude what are you watching what the
[ __ ]
it's military family [ __ ] what are
you wearing
it's a fanny ho you can't eat through
the [ __ ] pantyhose why are you even
wearing this
jesus scare the [ __ ] out of me you look
insane
i'm working why this is not working no
worries it's not
work it worked with what i used today
working
what is it you're just making yourself
cry with these reunion videos
yes dad i'm sad okay and i'm working
you're [ __ ] messed dude
what am i gonna eat yeah eva's coming
back
ethan ethan
you can't force me dan
let's go gotta clean you up i'm a bit
heavier than you thought aren't i
spilling coke oh you're laying in filth
dude
jesus you can't force anything of me
this is my work
this is my passion come on
heavier than you thought yeah a little
bit
that's right [ __ ] i've been drinking
now i've been drinking
doritos [ __ ] you [ __ ] smell
like [ __ ] yeah
move me [ __ ] you can't do
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
you are [ __ ] so we've all been down
bad
this in the past couple weeks are you
gonna kill dan
is ours he's dead in trouble i think
overall dan
did pretty okay considering we haven't
been canceled so
thank you dan you're a good bad dad good
man dan
[Applause]
yes good stuff i'm gonna come
yeah it's been hard i'm not gonna lie
dan saying he's gonna come
i'm gonna come so
i wanted to get your take on this okay i
waited for the story because i wanted to
ask you about this
okay ash ashton kutcher
oh you said it yeah i was i knew i was
gonna come with a
picture for their action puncher
and myla mia mila no
mia me i mean
say they don't believe in bathing their
kids
you've read this i saw the article
let me read that let me read the details
they said on
a podcast that they don't believe in
bathing often
and i guess they're talking for
themselves too it rids your bodies of
oils yeah that's what soap does
they that's what that that's why you
bathe uh they only wash their vitals
private areas and armpits each day
at that point just get in the shower so
they wash their [ __ ]
privates and only watch the kids when
they're visibly dirty
me myla mila mila all of a sudden i
can't say her name i know her name
mila mila mentions that she never bathes
her newborn child
ashton adds if you can see the dirt on
them clean them he said otherwise
there's no point
kusher says he does wash his armpits and
crotch daily and nothing else
ever and has a tendency to throw some
water on my face
after a workout and get all the salt out
thoughts ew some weird hips my thoughts
aren't you
i mean i have i don't know we've been
through that
phase but the which phase of like a
newborn because she said
their new the newborn they they don't
watch it ever
and it's like you it's really
i i think that's gross because they sit
in a diaper all day
and sometimes they have this like not
sometimes actually when they're
early like newborn they have a lot of
like really gross diarrhea
kind of poop like it's almost always and
yeah like i'm starting to remember but
so i don't know i find that really gross
listen people have been bathing for tens
of thousands of years i think we're fine
you guys i think the invention of like
running hot water is [ __ ] awesome i
mean like we
sometimes we wouldn't bathe him every
day
that's fine no they're saying yeah
you know i think bathing is great you
guys and i don't think you guys need to
be all
again people have been bathing every day
for tens of thousands of years we made
it
we made it we've arrived
i'm not becoming a billionaire to stop
showering like ashton is a billionaire
also if you're at the point of washing
your genitals and armpits what's the
deal
you're monster you're savage just step
in the shower these people are savages
they're taking
bars of soap to their [ __ ] junk what
about your feet
like but your whole damn body they must
stink bruh
hahahaha i peed in my basement
but also i i the thing that really it's
like if you don't want to shower that's
fine but your baby needs a [ __ ] bath
dude
yeah i never watched i don't know with
kids like
now that theodore kinda is uh grown up
he actually gets more and more dirty
throughout the day because he
he plays and he like i don't know he's
in the sand all day
plays in the playing playground it's
like they get really dirty
the thing is too these kids are not
gonna understand they're gonna be like
okay i don't have to shower they're
gonna grow up with horrible hygiene
because kids don't understand how to
take
you have to shower so they're going to
grow up being all [ __ ] like they're
going to be like pig pen
from charlie brown it's just weird it's
a weird take i didn't know people out
there just watching the armpits and
crotch
so oh my god i forgot to show this
um this is actually kevin hart
this is a visual representation of uh
them changing their description
on the trailer store well trailers flip
dude yeah you see that
flipped hard when he realizes the app is
flipped i can't believe they wrote
the app as a defamatory statement
i mean that logo was clearly flipped i i
don't know what to say it's so
awkward anyway you talk about trailer
all day
by the way it's like i'm still thinking
about it like even when theodore eats
you get the food all over and we get so
sticky
kids throughout the day kids are by the
end of the day i can't wait to watch it
get really dirty
yeah they're disgusting listen guys
take a bath please do it for everyone do
it for the world
some pediatricians are saying that it's
enough it's sufficient
not mine they're saying that well at
least a few that i've seen right now are
saying that culturally
uh we as americans have got used to
showering them too much but right now
one or two a week unless they're dirty
unless they're doing you know playing
outside or something
that's i mean i think at the very first
stages i think that's fine
you're not a newborn or whatever the
newborn stage i think that's fine
well it's in direct response to this
article so yeah
but i mean it's it's still sparking
controversy i mean you hear
both sides but people are a lot of the
doctors
but also with kids the shower is
actually it's like really important as
part of the night routine
when you try to teach them to go to
sleep at night
and you know sleep the whole night you
kind of have to
make a night routine for them and it's
always like
dinner shower you know put pajama
read a book go to sleep it's kind of
like the basics
i'm getting anti-vaxx vibes from them
[Music]
i can see that any intel on that
please take off your mask i'm getting
mad anti-backs vibes from
ashton and mila
eli you want to talk about um
there's a lot of good stuff left
we have a victoria's secret karen it's
like an attack on titan i think because
this is the attack oh no this is
something else
wait where is it where's the attack on
titan i didn't include it because i felt
like it
do you want to watch that yeah let's
totally watch it you thought it was too
graphic or something well this is
there's a lot of
punches being thrown back and forth it's
so good let's watch it let's watch
they're like
super tall it's like a group of
all cairns yeah like the tallest women
i've ever seen in my life attacking the
dude okay
and it's like attack on titan karen
pretty amazing
but while you keep that up let's watch
victoria's secret karen okay people say
in the chat they're not anti-vaxx
i googled it i didn't see anything about
that take it back don't show me
i did see an article titled that they're
not planning on passing down their money
to their kids
first they don't wash them they don't
get any money i mean what's going on in
this family
what the [ __ ] oh man
i would give theodore something i mean
we don't have we need to
make a will but like i wouldn't leave
him like with nothing
where we're talking about will well
they're saying if they died or
yeah when they die they're saying i'm
not leaving any money to the kids
i think the kids should get everything
well they probably just don't want to
turn into like douches or something
they want that make them earn their way
or something but still your kid
here let's watch the victoria karen so
here you'll enjoy this
this is a wild one man it's a whole ride
tell me what you think either you
narrate this okay no it's cute that's
cute
now you are oh my god
oh my god
do you see this oh my god
i never thought nothing like this would
happen to me she just tried to run and
hit me
and now she did you see what's happening
i don't know what happened before but
you tried to hit her oh my gosh
cameron had a breakdown she tried to hit
me
at your workers she tried to hit me
she tried to hit me now i want security
for you
[Music]
oh my god you should have thought about
that before you did what you did
oh my god this don't even feel real
this do not feel right i thought at
first she was laughing so she was crying
well i think when she realized she was
being filmed she was she laughing at
first
let's go back this is so confusing no i
think they were having a fight
and then when she realized oh my god
when she realized she was being filmed
then she went into breakdown mode
yeah she charged me if i wanted to duck
she would
oh no you just wanted security for me
right i want security for you now
no don't cry no no no i want you to call
security
[Music]
i don't know why this is happening to me
she's here to get free plan
ladies and she gentlemen more than she
bargained for you get what you pay for
dude i didn't realize victoria's secrets
was such like a trashy place
so you're giving out free underwear you
got fights going down
people having breakdowns screaming i
thought victoria secret was like a
classy place
i've been to one and it wasn't like that
are you saying they're not all like this
i don't think they're giving out like
free panties you know
i wish they were like this they're so so
[ __ ] boring
lena's always in victoria's secret i'm
just awkwardly standing
embarrassing to be in there not really
what are you a five-year-old i don't
know what's embarrassing
well i've gotten dragged in there by my
mom you've gotten dragged in there by
you you're going
with your mom with your mom i get it but
going with your wife
or girlfriend whatever i'll do one
better i got dragged in there by my
grandmother what's that
i got dragged in there by my grandmother
countless times
yeah it was mine what uh be there for
the free panties no just
i mean i was five or six seven whatever
my mom did that to me too i just
and she made me go in the dressing room
with her oh that's [ __ ]
bruised yeah sorry that's crazy
what did i i don't remember what i saw i
mean i was young you blocked it out yeah
that was i'm sure some horror [ __ ]
horse sounds like you did block it
i love my grandmother not in that way
though you know how old do you think
you were he said five five six seven
around that age
okay she's playing some naked or just
like underwear
well she had to put the underwear on
and you blocked it out yeah so much
makes sense now not a place i want to go
amy said so much makes sense about you
yeah that's why i'm [ __ ] up
you know from a traumatic experience
i've seen the joker
yeah happened so granny's secret
well anyway back to the camera
please please please this is the
weirdest
reaction oh you know what i just found a
shot interesting it looks like ryan
kavanagh was actually spotted
getting free panties and victoria's
secrets
sounds like he's down bad she's there
for the free panties
no why don't she walk away from me no i
was here no no no no
we're not doing this why don't i walk
away from her why don't you get away
from me she could get away
go wherever you want to go yeah that's
one of the most audacious parts this
video they're asking
the african-american lady to leave they
are
yeah they're saying you just because
they're like i don't want the scene
but yeah just why doesn't the girl just
walk away just leave why are you like
when it gets
really weird oh my god oh my god
this is like
i don't know how you even i don't know
what happened before this but it sounds
like you
i don't bro i don't know but this is
weird bro
yeah another detail the black woman is
also muslim
i believe she's wearing a scarf and uh i
think what happened was the white
uh lady at first attacked her and then
she pulled out her phone and that's when
this all began
oh so you think it was like a racial
slash uh religious thing
i mean very well plausible especially
being
you see the security guard asking her to
leave as well yeah that's [ __ ] up
just drag her out like dan dragged
myself
wow you want to see attack on titan
kerins
wait there's a part two to that there is
sand yeah i've seen way more
didn't tradeless virgins well send me
that and i'll wait for the to do the
attack on titan kerins
oh by the way quick announcement guys
h3tv our new youtube channel
is up in action we just posted our first
you'll be careful there's a fake one
wait
this is a fake one yeah oh wow sam
what the [ __ ] there's so many fake ones
yeah there's a lot
wait did they ever respond sam i'm gonna
send this discord
he's asking if he can get this one
removed youtube responded
so you guys make sure you don't
subscribe to a fake one don't subscribe
to the fake [ __ ] get the real cam said
they did respond
so there's apparently they made a new
channel and they have every single video
ripped with thumbnails and everything
damn did oh you're already working on it
is this is the first this is the first
[ __ ] result too
god he literally
youtube leave me the [ __ ] alone where's
my channel oh is it because you did
forever
well no the youtube channel is called
youth h3tv
h3tv we made our first ever video i want
to share with you guys
i can't find my own channel
it's all these ripoff people how do i
know ryan kavanaugh is not
operating this fake h3tv
i refuse to click it i have to find it
the legitimate i got it
so here we are h3tv
i just posted these so we can have it on
one place but here's our first video
i'm afraid that that thumbnail is too
graphic youtube gets really weird about
like thumbnails that are too gross i
think i think it's the
i think it's the green putrid we
actually did that one time about like
covered and then they
they dinged it oh they said it's too
yeah
yeah i think we need someone spraying in
my face cam
like use abe's hand spraying on my face
that's not better but i think
i think you don't just show his hand
with the bottle you don't need to
it's good this is interesting we're
making the sausages
so anyway you guys should go over
subscribe and watch
our content we have it linked right now
in the chat i'm very excited about h3tv
dude these things are crazy i don't like
these
i don't think that i don't think we can
get away with that title poop spray to
the face
youtube's like nah [ __ ] no i'm not going
to kill anyone right
poops right what were we thinking you
were giggling
yeah it was a bad idea how about stink
spray that's not as good bag of
tournaments
i still like the i don't like that i
made ian smell my ass
what'd it be i made ian smell my ass
title
i made ian smell my ass yeah that's much
better
what about the the challenge one we
talked about
what was it i don't know
this is how a challenge this is how
kanye makes his albums
yeah yeah it's all making a lot more
sense now well i'm gonna
we're doing a live show right now maybe
we could uh this is
the second part until after this
is good content
don't like the challenge in the title
reminds me of like youtube
like six years ago okay that's a good
point
i personally find that interesting i
[ __ ] in
ian's open mouth
and just do a big old thump and ian
sitting like this
they'll love that that's basically what
happened
this fart spray in ian's face was just
amazing yes i liked my own video if i
don't then who does
if i you know what i'm saying i'm not
embarrassed to like my own videos
um here you guys squirted [ __ ] people
want to see
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
here let's see your steven seagal please
stand up
doesn't she look like vlad or like
steven seagal ready to flip some dude
here come i don't know yeah no we could
see that
we see a little bumpy a little bumpy
it's hard to tell well she's wearing a
really
like sometimes i wear certain things
that
i look really pregnant in them that's a
good one well that's why steven skull
dressed like that because he's massive
oh what the [ __ ] oh just dropping your
boots on me just because i can't show
those are sick you want to stomp on my
face mommy no
you want to stomp on my eyeball
[Laughter]
i dressed like the there's no
coincidence
oh yeah you need like a large format no
such thing as a coincidence
and the fact that we are energetically
aligned right now yeah means kavanaugh
bran cavanaugh swing both of us
there's no such thing as a coincidence
anyway it's very funny i end up
ian um somehow accepted two hundred
dollars
and it says in bold they get sprayed
surprised all of
no it's it's one full spray okay okay
ready
it's the worst thing i've ever smelled
by far but it's a good spray so i'm not
going to do two sprays
that was a full spray okay
it's the i'm telling you nothing about
these
you want to smell it yeah so so anyway
the reason we're talking about this
is that since eva wasn't here to
experience what we all did
i wanted to give her i'll give you just
a quarter spray
that's so not fair isn't fair we all
smelled it
but that's what you're gonna do like
what you did to ian to me no no no
no i'll spray it over here over there
and then it will you'll get a sense just
it'll spray over it
okay i'm not going to square you in the
face okay yeah
so here bring me what did i get for
doing that you get to entertain the
people you welcome back
yeah ian almost puked he ran off to the
bathroom we all thought of you
for a novelty yeah i'm sorry you got the
money right
yeah i did thank you well earned man
anyway we should change the title
because i don't think youtube's going to
[ __ ] be like no
okay let's do it later let's do it later
ian will do anything for 200
i learned that about it that's a good
title
that is a pretty good title i just
ripped ass oh i was like
what is this sound all right right now
to cover it wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait now you've adopted
a spray this is right
nothing like this bro it's so horrible
yeah it's gonna even mask
okay so people say
everybody's saying stop the baby not
good for babies no stop
she's pregnant we've had this yeah we
had this
not toxic it literally the chat does not
agree with you
well what does chad know it literally
says non-toxic it's just a novelty spray
you guys uh
okay we'll go over do not harm the baby
don't do that please
no she's pregnant i'm gonna go all the
way over here
i have to sit next to you no
i'm too close oh you're saying okay i
don't know what you mean i'm just no i
said i'm going to sit next to you i'm
just going
afterwards yes okay so ready so i'm
going to just do one spray torch
okay no doubt
ethan sprayed it and then give it a
little waft
give it a little waft
oh my god oh wow
oh that's so
gross ew that's disgusting
that's really gross
it like it's like it's choking you
my god it's like right inside my throat
no actually people ask me how far do you
spray it
he's actually he was pretty he was about
like 10 feet away
it was it was pretty far she's out
i need to wash my hands yeah
all right they're both just out
well we've lost both both of our hosts
everyone um
so give us just a minute wait you
smelling it back there
i don't know get the [ __ ] out of the
seat what are you doing oh yeah
what are you doing yes so i will smell
this ash
to sit in the seat um
[Music]
hold on a second let me just hit you
with this real quick
i hope this doesn't make you sound like
a douche thank you dan
uh in the meantime why don't i read some
of these super chats we have
why not i like the twilight movies lizzy
s yeah i do like the twilight movies
pitch
donated 50 bucks hi h3 ela oh well it's
addressed to ela oh well
we'll let her know when she gets back
she looks absolutely glowing
i also have to say a general thank you
ever since i told my nude modeling story
on make ethan laugh
i've actually been getting rehired
non-stop i don't
what uh sure cool i mean that's cool
congrats
can't say i really remember that
how do i convince my job to get those
butthole chairs in office oh
and cam actually linked it if anybody
missed it what is it [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
that's what that's how you pronounce it
right [ __ ] bussy
busty or guess [ __ ] but yeah i guess
whatever
uh [ __ ] bussy you know
that was our boy uh what did ethan call
him brent rockman
or is that was was that his real name
brentman rock
bretman rock bretman rock right right
and he
kept calling him brent rockman yes yes
wow is it reaching you now dan i could
smell it over here now i hate
i don't know that's your breath maybe i
brought it back
it away wafted away from us
ethan is uh over talking about the title
and the thumbnail for other video ethan
uh quick correction we're live to the
last episode you can't live with it over
here having psych conversations he's
eating pizza
thank you guys for putting that out god
bless
eating pizza while in the [ __ ]
oh it smells like gone actually yeah
it's moved over to a b
apparently
[Music]
you want life i think there's some
people that are mad that you did that to
you
why i just i feel like you should know
i checked with the doctor i checked with
the doctor he checked with the doctor
it's not toxic i'm not even making a
joke i did
okay i believe you he just got a [ __ ]
face
he always checks everything for me
listen i'm just why are people mad at me
i'm just telling you the feedback that
we're getting you think i don't care
about the baby
like i care way more than you do trust
me
[Laughter]
i care way [ __ ] more than any of you
guys mad
in the comments
[Music]
trust me okay how are you eating pizza i
don't smell it anymore
god you're crazy i really don't
i think i smelt it too much yesterday
ian i don't know how you did that
got to get that money how are you alive
ian please stand up
please oh do we have the attack on titan
um
karen's yep i sent it to you by the way
i sent you the second part if you want
to and the second part as well
oh let's watch the second part first
it's pretty good i'm interested in that
oh wow this part i think wow oh
i can show you okay 20 minutes this
whole thing is 21 minutes holy [ __ ]
this time stump is where you
[Music]
oh my god i mean she's having like a you
keep lying saying i'm threatening you so
i'm recording to protect myself
she's clearly unhealthy
[Music]
it's unwell i don't know she's unwell
i think she's not for me i think she's
faking it
because she doesn't want her to keep
recording her
but at the same time you have to be
really unwell to do this in the first
place yeah
[Music]
yo the employees are [ __ ] idiots for
letting this go on like what the [ __ ]
are you guys
called the police what are they supposed
to do tackle her
i mean when she's charging another
customer maybe yeah
i'm not interfering for minimum wage or
whatever they're paying i don't
know that's the manager oh they have
security guards i'm sure they called the
security guards
no i
yes that's true that's the least they
could do yeah she's saying i'm
threatening
i'm not interfering in that for like
this to protect me fifteen dollars an
hour hell no
her white ass on my black ass
[Music]
i gotta stop coming here
and this goes on for 20 minutes love
i mean the best
people are trying to help her and ask
her to step out the store she
i'm of course i'm not helping why would
i have you trying to hurt me
[Music]
how could she help anybody would you see
what's to do
please come here now i'm feeling
threatened
what
thank you thank you peace and love
um all right where's the attack on titan
karen
that was in there too i don't
okay here it is gang of giant karen's
attack a little this is the title these
are my words
gang of giant cairns attack a little
mexican guy
what those are theirs are not my words
but it is accurate let's be honest
they're like way bigger than him maybe
they're just seven feet tall and he's
like a normal size dude i don't know
it's hard to tell but
it's pretty good i enjoyed this one
walk away they're just
tall girls who are also wearing heels
these are just that these are abnormals
but here comes the colossal wait
wait for it i love how he just was like
stop
you oh here comes food she's coming to
break the wall
yo he's able to take them down like
relatively peacefully i mean props to
him
here comes the classic colossal oh god
she's stomping
[Laughter]
they must be like volleyball players
yeah
well that was good and props to the
quote little mexican guy
that is how i phil if i try to wear
heels i feel like i'm a giant like it's
just not someone
like that though someone would play it
into that i can't
i would feel insecure if you were so
much taller than me it's awful
it's an awful feeling maybe i wouldn't i
don't know maybe like
way taller than anyone in the room it's
awful the chat said that guy is captain
levi
i'm sorry if you don't understand attack
her right on titan but that's hilarious
he's captain levi
short like king of killing the titans
that's true it is totally captain levi
gracefully dispatching them
did you update it cameron or you can
update on the channel i'm looking at the
channel
yeah um
so oh we also wanted to introduce
lovebot got an upgrade lovebot 2.0 is on
a new
robot
half-hearted clap the last one was just
i think we
busted it yeah well i don't know
yeah it was defective that thing was
definitely but don't we have a video
prepared
to introduce the new bot
uh no silence uh what i will be talking
yeah i'll load it up it's gonna need a
couple of minutes
oh my god can you guys see this oh
you're so quiet
yeah sorry i was oh yeah what do you got
what is that he printed out fun oh
wait wait is that you print that or
something
yeah because i thought it was so cool
yeah it is really cool
what's happening nobody cares sorry love
nobody's
yeah yeah i'm excited about the new bot
is is
super fast um will you post full h3 tv
stream
the idea is to leave those on twitch no
it's all gonna go no no no everything's
going on h3tv
everything's going on h3tv with peace
and love peace and love are you going to
post the full
stream well the last one was kind of a
mess so
not that one but maybe other ones that
are more
coherent i guess dinosaurs we don't know
just go to h3tv with peace and love
and watch out for the imposters because
apparently
it's impossible to find the real one
i think we're gonna have to come back to
this video what happened we can't show
it
it sent me the link it's not uploaded
it's not floating but it's so short
it's a minute 45. i mean i'm i'm
doing it now but it's gonna need some
time a minute 45
how long does that take to upload i mean
i don't know downloading it right now i
mean
all right well in the meantime we have a
sec a weird
tick tock segment for weird the weird
amish
apparently there's amish tick tock you
know there's like a tick tock
sub genre for everything yeah well the
amish have their own
tick tock don't ask me how
they're not allowed for technology yeah
they're not allowed for technology so i
don't know if it's the amish
or uh almost adjacent people but here's
the first video
um asking god for a normal family okay
that's kind of like we're gonna be over
today and can i also have a small blues
wrap blue raspberry slushie
a sausage mcmuffin i can't give me
something over here and can i also have
but why is she using a phone isn't that
an isn't that
contrary to they're really they're like
rebellious
clearly she hates being amish
interesting and she spent enough time on
tick tock to know
okay okay so we have more details these
are kids who
smuggle their phones into amish
communities
obviously there's no technology allowed
or they obtain them
well on their rumspringa
which is their temptation journey to
decide whether or not to remain amish
so did you know about that no so the
oh i'm getting a call from someone from
youtube great here mute it for a sec
let me give it to someone else
the best podcast in the world take it
from me jc
over chair xp baby we podcast
now you're watching h to the three three
three three you're watching h two three
three three
three you're watching h to the three
three three
you're
we'll do the real raw ritual with more
an eg
sharing laugh with the ring just see how
low jimmy
they said we wouldn't come back but you
we always do embrace from the ashes like
the phoenix on the flex back to two
you're watching h to the three
are we back all right hey guys sorry
important call
was that susan it was susan she was just
saying hi
she was complaining about the new
thumbnail okay
and i was saying susan when are you
going to shut down kingston's channel
and she said well ethan we're working on
it
i said good got to shut down keemstar
um okay so oh the the um it's pretty
interesting the rum springer so the
amish when they come of age
they go on a temptation journey out into
the world of technology
and drugs and sex and they
see if it's tempts them enough to stay
out there in the world or to come back
and become staying on
an amish okay pretty interesting right
sounds like a good concept on
it's a great movie have you seen kingpin
right
now one of my all-time favorites uh
rebecca and her family talking [ __ ]
whoa language about how i showed my
ankle to ezekiel are these people for
real you guys
oh i guess there's copyrighted music
give me a little i need some volume to
understand this one
[Music]
okay turn it down i i don't get this one
i'll be honest
it's like inside jokes about being amish
what's what i'm getting so they're mad
that she showed her ankles to ezekiel oh
he's another like one day they're
like yo that [ __ ] yeah ankles
wow that is a deep amish cut
making abraham regret his life uh oh
abraham we're coming for you
repent now [ __ ]
this is your sign to go outside and make
abraham regret his
life
thank you
wait this is it okay
oh sh cause she's looking hot is that
the joke she can't do that did she
really amish
or is she doing gags because she's
showing way too much
amish very
provocative abraham is regretting his
life right now
amish boys discussing girls breasts
first ankles
this is not real breast first ankles
is that even a competition
i'm getting a lot of fakes in the chat
um
what some people are saying fake of
course
is fake the boys discussing
breasts they're animals you don't have
to oh
the boys discussing ankles or though
it's for the amish
it's for the amish well i don't know who
the [ __ ] else is getting the jokes out
of this
it has 5 000 likes so it's relatively
deep cut
interesting observation the
a group of amish boys speaking
pennsylvania dutch
baby
[Music]
settle down
all right the amish are out there living
their best life some dwight fruit ship
when he doesn't own a buggy hmm
yeah that's a problem that's a broke
[ __ ]
this is when he doesn't own a buggy
yeah i don't think this girl's serious
you guys
that's what they mean i think breaking
amish fan account
like breaking bad these yeah this girl's
not amish there's a
tv show called breaking amish about kids
yeah this girl's not honest she's just
doing gags god bless america
i appreciate her dedication to the amish
though
oh thank god thank you guys so anyway
introducing lovebot 2.0 we prepared a
little video for you guys
enjoy think today things are different
from here on forth
yeah okay guys high quality
high fidelity
looking really high quality but okay
let's let it ride
a full screen we got to see every pixel
1.0
2.0 let's see who's faster i'm gonna i'm
gonna shoot the gun and then you guys
start okay
ready first one to me wins ready set
go
go that's the new bot on the right by
the way if you didn't know
way faster way faster way more agile
and that thing turns on a dime what do
you think about the new bot
oh wait hold on there's more fight fight
yeah youtube please don't demonetize us
i know this is graphic content
some might consider it shopkins
2.0 is superior oh no
oh no no no no no no no no i load it up
all right lovebot i hate to say it
hasta la vista
that's it fantastic love what do you
think about your new bot
i like it dude it's bad something that
uh
you didn't see on that video i actually
have
underglow on my boat yeah you can kind
of rgb
underglow yeah yeah there's like there's
like racing
here you can see it here yeah like floor
lights right
yeah i mean fancy yeah you see that it
has multiple cameras
back up cameras floor cameras ah dude
you have a floor cam
oh yeah oh yeah it does and well
what's what wasn't very fun with a last
robot was
i i couldn't hit things it wouldn't
allow me to crash into things
right it happened exactly now though i
can just
ram into people actually yesterday when
i didn't realize uh
that like anti-crash thing was off i
crashed straight into a b
uh unintentionally of course
well i i i know we actually prefer it
like that i mean
right i prefer this spot to be able to
do damage and cause mischief
yeah i i took a to get rid around your
car
earlier that was kind of scary yeah i
saw you back there there
was like he's getting a little
comfortable around here
just off on his own well
did you want to talk about bachelor or
housewives or anything before we go hila
i know you're real passionate about that
sure um i mean there's still a lot that
we wanted to talk about but i guess it's
been it's been a while
the world like what like there's the
baby
yeah the babies did all this homophobic
stuff but i'm like i mean
yeah i mean guys it's pretty good yeah
we should talk about the baby
yeah this was so weird why did he do
this
it's so weird so the baby
i'm calling him you know what after this
he lost
the he lost the baby he's now the baby i
see
he's lost that respect on his name yeah
so the baby
made some questionable remarks on stage
at rolling loud
here they are break it down for you
after that
you didn't show up today with hiv aids
any of them dead essentially
the diseases that'll make you die two
three weeks put yourself on lightning
so it says if you didn't show up with
hiv aids or diseases they'll make you
die in two weeks
put your light up
and continue if i didn't understand that
one if
he says if your [ __ ] smell like water
but yeah
again it's he's referencing stds he's
he's saying this up fellas if you ain't
so clean
if it's clean because he's saying
if you don't and he says if you so i'm
confused he's saying
he likes women whose vaginas smell like
water
[Music]
lady if you smell like water put a cell
phone like that
okay got it [ __ ] smell like water
wet ass pee work what a way to um hype
up a show
it's like you can tell the crowd's
really feeling it too how about the
people that like the music let's see
those phones up
ladies if you haven't had cancer yeah
losers who have never had cancer put
those phones up the phone up
if you've had cancer put your phone down
beta loser
fellas lights up fellas if you ain't
sucking a dick in the parking lot put
your cell phone like this
and again why he says fellas if you're
not sucking
d word in the part dick in the parking
lot
put your now listen
i don't think dudes are the only ones
sucking dick in the parking lot let's be
real
and i mean shout out
it's it's just weird if you're in that
situation i'd be like
well i didn't but i mean like i don't
know i feel like if you were caught up
in the moment you want to be thinking
exactly about what he's saying and
you're like well
i didn't suck any you know but it's a
weird i don't know it's a weird
situation to be
well i'll break it down for you i love
his height man is like
keep it [ __ ] real tell me suspect has
a [ __ ] let's be real
it's the hype mentality no he's hyping
him up oh yeah
he goes some of y'all are suss let's be
real which is like we suspect you have
been gay
so he's saying don't like don't put your
phone up if you're suss
i think in other words okay so let's
break that down
um so he got a lot of [ __ ] for that
homophobic he says it's not homophobic
but it is homophobic and let me explain
why
you didn't show up today with hiv aids
idiots
first of all i don't know how many times
it needs to be said having hiv
does not make you a bad person people
get hiv all kinds of different ways
it's a horrible disease that nobody
should have and it's no
and like you're not it doesn't make you
a bad person
and then the way he defends his
statements is really crazy
yeah and anyone can get it by the way
it's not a gay disease
this is so weird i mean people are there
to to celebrate your music why are you
coming out with
some weird debate the baby
well and then so but also hiv is not
that funny like it's just
such a horrible disease and it's just
caused so much pain and suffering it's
like
you know it's like not not really not
really cool
if you've had hiv leave your phone down
[ __ ]
put a cell and first of all i've been
with women who
i just thought i [ __ ] up
i feel like everything i said from that
point on would be taking the
i'm not talking about you i was slept
with a girl in college who [ __ ]
[ __ ] stink the whole room up oh but
it wasn't her fault she was just
that was just her biology so i'm just
saying
yeah also some people are involved with
what also some people are born with it
you know that's what i'm saying
some people just born with stinky
vaginas and that's just what it is
not always what was that zack i was
referring to hiv but yeah
oh born with hiv yeah yeah that happens
too yeah
well pete keep your light down
fellas lights up lights up in the
parking lot put your cell phone
and again it's more homophobe because
he's like fellas if you're sucking dick
in the parking lot
excuse me anyone could be sucking dick
in the parking lot
okay and if anyone listen if you're
sucking dick in the parking lot
i still want you subscribed i'm not i'm
not in a position to say no to anyone
sucking a ding-dong you know what i'm
saying i'll take everyone
keep it [ __ ] real
yeah super weird super weird yeah
and so anyway it got really off the
wheels when he started getting [ __ ] and
then tried
clearing things up okay so get ready for
him to clear things up hila
here he is
the lights went up gate or straight you
want to know why
because even my gay fans don't got
[ __ ] aids
stupid ass so you say you got a's my gay
fans they take care they
ain't going for that
he's not homophobic he just hates people
with aids specifically
specifically right right because he's
saying gay not all of my gay fans have
aids i just hate
those nasty gays right right his friends
are s tier gays
right yeah i have i have top gays only
i mean it's just it's insane how does he
miss it this much in this year
the lights wanna get straight you wanna
know why
because even my gay fans don't hang it
[ __ ] aids
stupid ass what do
by the way his voice sounds
why are you gay why are you gay
the baby the baby exactly
you lost the honorific duh my dude
you're now
you know what i'm saying on the street
yeah you come out
then i said you ain't stuck in a rolling
lab parking lot
put your cell phone light up you know
what my gay fans did put that
[ __ ] light up
because my gay fans they ain't got
they ain't going for that they got class
but why are you even
bringing it up why are you even having a
conversation about like
love my gay fans just not the ones that
are sucking dick in the parking like
they've been degenerating not the messy
ones
yeah there's pl there's the women are
sucking dicks in the parking lot too my
dude
is your problem with gay seconds in the
parking lot or people sucking dick in
the parking lot
seems like it's about gays yeah exactly
have that same energy for anyone get
sucking dick in the parking lot
ain't second no you know parking lot you
gotta get a room
a good one five star hotel for them or
goddamn
yeah you gotta wait today go to the crib
man just gonna be out here just
doing you know anything yeah if they're
a fan of me they got them they on some
big dog [ __ ] we ain't just going for
nothing
you know even my gay fans got standards
y'all trippin
even my gay fans have standards
of course my normal my straight fans
have standards but even
my gay fa do you hear the it's like
do you hear what he's saying yeah
like gay people don't have standards but
even my gay fans have standard negative
attention and energy
upon yourselves and the ones that's
doing it it's people who didn't even
attend the show
what do i need to attend the show liz
it's sad
well i didn't see him holding his his
light up so what does that mean so
anyway that's him trying to clear things
up
uh a clothing company who's working with
boo who uh is reviewing relationship
with him what that means
somebody threw a shoe at him i actually
i saw this first and i didn't know but
this is because of his remarks pissed so
many people off so someone threw a shoe
at him
put a hand in the hell with his sailboat
and turn the [ __ ] light on if you
special too
who the [ __ ] through that [ __ ]
busted ass goddamn adidas
i love that he's like if you're if
you're not stuck in the parking lot
light up if you are stuck in deck in the
parking lot throw your shoes at me
sam made an excellent point in the
office when whenever he said
adida he said is that the scene she said
is that the singular form of adidas
[Laughter]
yeah that's interesting uh the baby
continues i tell fans to put a cell
phone light in the air and you'll start
a million man march
well no nobody's marching
i told y'all digest that wrong but i
ain't gonna lie
i'm impressed now show the same amount
of support when a racist cop killed one
of our black ass
you're not bro it's not about that and
i'm sure people
did we can do both last year when yeah
it was like the biggest thing
with george following don't try to twist
this and the [ __ ] black people being
killed by cops
anybody who ever done ever been affected
by aids or hiv
y'all got the right to be upset what i
said was insensitive
and even though i have no intentions on
offending
anybody so my apologies okay
we have an apology but the lgbt
community i ain't tripping on y'all do
you your business is your business
as long as you don't have aids
apparently
like i said it's really it just seems to
be about the aids thing he's really
owning in on this aids
and for any brands networks or artists
that like to profit off of black
rapper's influence on culture
without understanding it or having the
patience to deal with
what comes i may have unplugged
something yeah it looked like it was
is it all good seems fine now okay
without understanding or having the
patience to deal with what comes with
the position we play in our culture
keep your money next time us whatever i
i don't know what that means humans do
it's like dude this is not about
god bless this is not about hashtag god
bless
friends thank you thank you for throwing
in the god bless again this is about the
baby
you're diverting the baby
the baby other than that y'all cheer the
[ __ ] up and be proud of who you are
because you can't make me feel less
myself
okay stupid
dula lipa who recently collapsed with
him called him out
zach any thoughts on doula lipa yeah
zach
[ __ ] this guy man that's my thoughts on
it
no no no i don't know no comments
sex
i don't know you anymore you've changed
bro
i like her music all of a sudden he's
not making a comment about duo alipa
which is fair you're being respectful
[Music]
i appreciate her um i get bummed out
seeing stuff like that because
i was kind of like into his music and
stuff and it seemed cool but
this is awful i feel like you can say
for sure he's homophobic
yeah like come on dude um
do a
i'm surprised and horrified at the
baby's comment
i really don't recognize this as the
person i worked with i know my fans know
where my heart lies and i stand 100 of
the lgbt community
we need to come together to fight the
stigma and ignorance around hiv aids
that's pretty good considering like they
just had a collab so i mean probably
yeah
but yeah i agree that's those are
harmful stereotypes for sure
having aids or aids does not make you a
bad person for [ __ ] sake
come on you guys
oh and then so by the way bonus meme
do you know why the baby is called the
baby
well this guy who's trying to call out
other people
[ __ ] got his name because he
used to cruise around in a diaper
now now if i'm the dude cruising around
in a diaper
i'm just saying those that live in glass
houses shouldn't
throw rocks you know what i mean
by the way that's gayer then whatever he
said
that's like a weird fetish right there
my dude
well it doesn't have to be that means
it's gay i okay i'm just
right it's not
in his own mind if the baby a homophobic
guy
saw a dude in a diaper cruise around
like that i think he'd feel
uncomfortable
is that fair or bad uh sorry yeah maybe
i don't know
yeah okay whatever this is like one of
the first times i could recall like in
hip-hop at least because you know i love
hip-hop but it does have a
huge problem with homophobia and that's
one of the first
examples i could think of of a hip-hop
artist being held accountable
for something he said that's true
hip-hop does have a problem with
homophobia
yeah i guess i haven't really seen it
with um
current music well people have gotten a
lot better but yeah
usually it's in lyrics and stuff and
things get kind of lost in lyrics
but the dude's home you're cruising
around with the diaper dude i mean if
you're really talking [ __ ] about groups
of people
[Music]
he forgot who he he's really changed bro
he forgot who he was
yeah wait
what apple removed the song of the baby
after all this jesus white song apple
has removed dua lupa's song levitating
featuring the baby from all apple music
curated playlists
well so that's it you want to talk about
bachelor
um where do we
where do we begin oh my god
good question how long we've been going
dan
uh two hours and 25 minutes we have food
here maybe we just wrap it up
it is four which means we have to leave
soon
let's see if the channels we can find
anyway guys go to h3
tv please watch our stuff you guys
and it's not showing up why the [ __ ] is
that showing up you guys it keeps
showing other people's content
[Laughter]
bro i can't find my own channel
okay i found it so
oh so here's the new thumbnail what do
you guys think let's take a poll
oh this is better but we have to change
the the title we can't i don't think we
can put poop in the title
that's a pretty good thumbnail do you
like it mm-hmm so now
so now we need like a gross spray to the
face or
let's see you guys have any suggestions
you guys have any
i saw that some people said that if you
don't post the whole vod
other people will um you know pirate it
and post it well yeah true this one was
a mess
because like the first half was
that first half was just the vr breaking
every five seconds
yeah it was like a whole disaster we
don't have to post that part we could
just post the whole recipe that's my
favorite part
you guys have suggestions for titles i
need help here
poop spray to the face challenge gone
wrong
dookie i like the challenge one what you
like the challenge
yeah challenge in the title how about
dookie spray to the face
dookie dookie is less offensive than
poop
stink spray stink spray
somebody said stink
[Music]
liquid fart liquid fart that's pretty
good
fart spray yeah fart spray is probably
good
do fart spray camera
[Music]
we're doing the ouija board challenge is
it really do we you guys like challenge
or should i just say fart spray to the
face gone wrong oh god
i don't know let's talk about it out
there please
i don't know it's pretty interesting
pretty [ __ ] interesting i'm going to
start clicking around the
sound website i will say as someone
watching this who is trying you know
when i was
before i'm trying to cover even sorry
let me think of something no what i was
going to say is uh
i would love to learn this stuff like
watching as a fan if i had a youtube
channel i find it very interesting
you know of course it's interesting dan
the hater
dan goes i'm not a hater his on you know
what his own popular tank was
he goes here's my unpopular tape i'm not
a hater
ethan's the hater he's in popular
are you equating being a hater with an
[ __ ] so you've just been calling me
an [ __ ] on this show for the last
three years
yes and
okay i agree with that i don't think
this is interesting
well anyway we're wrapping it up though
guys thank you so much for watching
welcome back means everything thank you
for watching it was fun i had a lot of
fun going over the complaint so
making lemonade out of lemons as they
say obviously being sucks to being sued
and sued and sued by ryan duchamp
but we're making the best of it
run for the cube is live what the [ __ ]
does that look like what
no way
this is the weirdest [ __ ] in the
world you guys know about run for the
cube
this is a deep cut what the [ __ ] look at
the title
unauthorized cia enhancement
interrogation and torture techniques
no that's a [ __ ] title it says
started watching
may 16 we're the only ones watching wait
has this been going since
may come coming one watching we're the
only person watching this
well i know you rate him well i know
youtube
i want to read by
sponsored messy wearing 4-h oh
what is going on [ __ ]
insane one watching pete couture
unauthorized cia enhanced interrogation
did you hear from
yes you don't remember we had a uh know
your meme competition
uh with him and we recorded a bunch of
answers
no i [ __ ] up i blew his cover she's
doing work well we didn't really like
cover anything but
well that's what he gets we're having a
live stream called unauthorized caa
enhanced interrogation and torture
techniques
with one person watching me another's
fifty-five somebody said dan i'll donate
money
for you to shut this [ __ ] down we've
gone off the rails
everyone's saying hi to elon in the chat
hi
[Laughter]
i mean it's all supposed to be
uncomfortable and weird
hmm i thought he was actually making
kids content
what no when at what point did you get
that impression oh there was there was
the whole
there was this creepy i know but there
was this pretense that like this is a
real channel for kids
no luck let's go video
sort by most popular
yeah the red belly this is the one we
reacted to with 18 million views
jelly belly peppers
youtube was showing this to kids i swear
to [ __ ] this is well you know it was
doing all kinds of yeah
they were showing a lot worse to kids
yeah this one has 18 million
g-line be views pete rat gumai kant on
g-ly beeline yeah that's nice
it's so crazy that's not for kids
so here you go surgery on the eyes and
[ __ ] be right
back
okay
donated twenty dollars said i just got
here what is being sued thing about
you're gonna have to get over here yeah
start the episode over because any
donations or comments we should be
before we go
uh well there was that one uh
that i read off some when you guys had
uh
gone off actually one was for you ela
when you were um recovering from the
fart spray so i'll read it again
uh eli you're absolutely glowing also i
have to say general thank you
uh to you ever since i told my nude
modeling story on make ethan laugh i've
actually been
getting rehired non-stop you broke the
curse
oh great wow congratulations we're
breaking curses left and right
i'm glad that show helps someone yeah
yeah there was no purpose
it's a joke
i like the twilight movies you guys want
to watch this whole video together
oh did you up update the title camera i
think we gotta run
ethan wrap it up oops or no no fart
spread
i think fart might be knocking okay
either we're let's get out we'll go
without you
again zach is important no it's me
that's me i'm spamming the uh thank you
thank you
thank you everyone actually we'll see
you on monday live
we're doing h3tv on monday and thursday
tuesday families
wednesdays off the rails thursdays day
street tv
fridays after dark we are not [ __ ]
stopping
five days a week you know what it is
[Music]
with more and e.t sharing life with the
ring just see
how low jimmy lee they said we wouldn't
come back but you we always do embrace
from the ashes like the peanuts on the
flex back to two
you're watching h2333 you're watching
h2333
you're watching h 2 3 3 3 3 you're
watching h 2
3 3 3.